okay
why don't we begin
hi everybody
see how many we got here
uh most of you um
i'm sure the others will show up
hopefully uh soon enough
so
welcome back um
we have today's lecture four
and
um
let's just remember what we've been
doing um
in the
last few lectures we were exploring
uh the regular languages as described by
finite automata and regular expressions
we showed how to convert them back and
forth
those two models to one another
and we also showed how to prove
certain languages are not regular now
remember finite automata are a very
um weak
model of computation they only have a
limited memory a finite memory um
and uh they still aren't able to do
certain things with their finite memory
but um
they are
you know um
if you compare them with
a general-purpose computer at least the
way we think about it
is
their uh
you know their capabilities are just
extremely limited and so
we're going to over the next uh few
lectures explore uh some more powerful
models we started doing that last time
uh the context-free grammars and as
we'll see there are certain things that
you can do i think we saw that last time
as well those are some things you can do
with context-free grammars that you
cannot do with finite automata
and uh but they still have their
limitations as we'll see um
so um
today what we're going to do we're going
to continue that discussion
uh by
looking at the definition of
context-free grammars in a more formal
way
uh one of the uh things that we do in
this course is develop practice with
formalism
and um so that that's going to be in the
spirit of that
we also are going to look at their
associated languages called the context
free languages so they're going to be
the counterpart for context-free
grammars of what the regular languages
are for the
finite automata of regular expressions
and then we're going to look at a an
automaton based model
which is the counterpart
to the grammars called the push down
automata and we'll see that those are
equivalent in power
and finally um well
and as part of that we will show how to
convert the context free grammars to the
push-down automata
and that's what that's what that's what
we're going to do today so we're going
to move on then and uh return to uh our
topic of context-free grammars that we
began last time and just to refresh your
memory um so here was that example of a
context free grammar that we gave last
time
and
it has
the way we're going to be writing
context-free grammars is using a bit of
a shorthand uh which looks like this
when you have multiple rules that have
the same variable on this on the left
hand side you can combine them into one
line
so these two rules over here
s goes to 0 s1 and s goes to r can be
written
in one line as a little bit more compact
way this is standard
as s goes to 0 s 1 or r that's where you
would read this
this is really two rules but written on
one line
okay
so uh as you recall uh from last time a
context-free grammar has terminals
variables and rules uh those are the
parts that we
speak of as well as one of the variables
being designate designated as a starting
variable which gets the whole thing
going so i'll talk remind you about how
that computation goes but um
so the variables are the symbols that
appear on the left-hand side of the
rules
the terminals are the other symbols
that appear in the grammar
and
the
we
take the grammar and we use it to
generate strings according to a certain
system and the system is that you start
out by writing down the uh starting
variable
and then once you've written down that
variable or whatever variables you have
written down you're allowed to
substitute them according to the rules
of the substitution rules that are in
the grammar so you can keep on replacing
the variables that you have with the
corresponding right hand sides
and then
you do that over and over again until
you don't have any variables left only
terminal symbols remain
and at that point you have generated a
string that's in the language of the
grammar
all right
so the
grammar's language is going to be
a language over strings
whose alphabet are the terminal symbols
so the terminal symbols in a certain
sense play the same role
as the input alphabet say for the finite
automata
okay the the the variables are kind of
internal working um symbols for the
grammar the terminals are sort of are
are the
symbols over which the language is is
written
okay we'll make that more precise in a
minute where when i give the formal
definition
so the result is the generated string
and the language of the grammar is the
language of all generated strings that
you can get using that grammar so
um and the important thing is that we
call that language a context free
language
okay so the that's like what we get from
that that's the analogous thing to the
regular languages but here we call them
context-free languages uh the things
that you can get from a context-free
grammar again just a quick recap of that
example we did last time
so you start out by writing the
start variable
and then i'm going to give you kind of
two views of that either in terms of the
tree of substitutions which we call the
parse tree or in terms of the resulting
string as you do the substitutions so
here is the uh parse tree here is the
resulting strings here are the
substitutions that you make um
and now we have r
um
coming from s and we have zero zero r
one one and now we have uh
r in turn becomes an
empty string and then uh the string that
we generated is zero zero one one that's
in the language of the grammar
and now uh if you
play with this a little bit you'll see
that the language of the grammar is all
strings that look like
runs of zeros followed by runs of ones
all right so uh is that clear
um i think we're gonna have a
um i think the next uh slide is gonna
have a
check in and so hopefully that'll uh
get us all together on the same page
with this
anyway um so here's our formal
definition anyway uh we have a
context-free grammar
is a four-tuple there are four parts of
context for grammar these are the parts
we've already been discussing uh the
variables the terminal symbols the rules
um the rules are always of the form a
variable
uh followed by you know with an arrow to
a string of variables and terminals
that's the way we write just write that
down so this is the form of the rule
and then we have the special start
variable and we all wrap that up into a
package this four tuple that's what the
context free grammar is
um
now we have here uh
and now
maybe a little bit overkill but let's
talk about what formally speaking what
the the way the grammar actually
processes
um and produces strings
um so
we're going to write uh the the standard
notation for this is that if you have
two strings of variables and terminals
so imagine you have an intermediate
string that you've generated in the
grammar so far
um
you know which might be like 0 0 s 1 1
from the previous line so that's an
intermediate string that is so far what
you've generated you're going to say um
maybe that's you and v might be the next
line down
uh
so that means we're going to write u
arrow v and that arrow is
the the word we're going to use is
yields we'll say u yields v
um if it can go from u to v just with
one substitution step
um
and then we'll write
u yields v in some number of steps or
actually we say u derives v
if it can go to u to v with some number
of substitutions instead of just one and
that's used with the um the yields arrow
with the star above it to mean some
number of
um another way of writing that is you
can say
u goes to v if there are a bunch of one
step moves that you can make which take
you from u to v
and that whole sequence is called a
derivation
of v from u
that's a sequence of steps that you go
through
doing these substitutions one by one to
take you from u to v according to the
rules of the grammar and lastly if u is
a starting
variable
then we call that sequence
just the derivation of v it could be the
derivation from the start variable but
that's kind of the assumed if you don't
say it's a derivation from anything the
derivation of v in the grammar is the
derivation of v from the start variable
it's just the sequence of substitutions
that you make kind of the you know what
you is
what i think you would expect
now the language of the grammar is the
set of all strings that um
of terminal symbols
that you can get from uh starting at the
starting variable of the grammar
okay and that's called a context-free
language as i mentioned before so it's a
context of free language it's the
language of of the grammar for some
grammar
okay so let's have a little check in
here again nothing too hard nothing to
get worried about anyway we're not
counting correctness uh here so um
let's just see
um i'm gonna give you two
uh things that look like grammars
which of them are actually grammars and
let me just pull that poll up uh here
okay so which of these are valid
grammars here
are they both
neither
i mean you can kind of make an argument
either you know either way for both of
them but both of them are kind of a
little have their own
a bit of weirdness to them uh in a way
if you if you if you
study them for a second
um okay that's pretty much converged um
share the results um
okay so um
so in fact
the correct answer is b
um
[Music]
and uh
why is only c2
first of all you know well what's wrong
with c1
c1 the problem with c1 is that the rules
have things besides a single variable on
the left hand side
so having a b1 on the left-hand side is
not legal in a context-free grammar
in fact there are other kinds of
grammars
there's a kind of grammar called a
context sensitive grammar the term
context free means you can replace the
variable
independent of its context in the
intermediate string so independent of
what's around it but here the this
substitution is going to you can replace
b but it depends on there being a one
next to it
um
this is called a context sentence set of
grammar but it's not the kind of
character we're going to be using which
are only context free grammar so c1 is
out
that's not a legit
context-free grammar
c2
the thing that's a little weird about c2
is if you try to generate a string in c2
you'll see
that
um there's no way to get rid of the
variables you're always going to be
stuck with the variable um now that
doesn't violate
the definition of a context-free grammar
so this is a context-free grammar but
but it's not going to be able to
generate any strings of only terminals
so this is a context-free grammar whose
language happens to be the empty
language but that's totally okay
so the correct answer here is b
that only c2 here is a valid
context-free grammar
okay um
common let's just see common question
does a string u derive itself
yes a string u derives itself uh
that's a little bit of a little bit of
an esoteric question there for us right
now but yes
um a string u in in this definition here
u arrow stars you is legit is illegal
maybe it isn't
uh according to the way i've written it
down here but it is it is uh a legal
thing it's not going to really matter
for you anyway but but it is illegal
okay let's continue um
let's do another somewhat interesting
example of a context-free grammar um
this is a grammar that is um
can generate arithmetical expressions
involving pluses and times
so here it is it has
how many rules well there are six rules
here each line represents two rules so e
goes to e plus t or t
t goes to t times f or f and f goes to
uh parenthesis e parenthesis or a
um
now so the
variables are going to be the symbols
that appear on the left hand side et and
f the terminal symbols which are going
to be the symbols of the language that
you're going to be generating um is
going to be the plus the time symbols
the parentheses are just terminal
symbols here so they're nothing not
playing any special role besides that
and then you have the a which is
representing kind of the um
operand on which those operators uh
would be working if there was actually
an expression you would use but they're
just symbols from the perspective of the
of the grammar
and lastly the start variable is going
to be as normally
appears on the upper left hand side
of the
grammar in terms of the way you write it
down
so sometimes you might specify a
different start variable but
otherwise if not specified it's that
it's the one in this corner here
okay so let's just see uh some examples
of uh using the grammar to generate
uh
a string so here is a string in the
language a plus a times a and and this
example will kind of reveal some other
interesting features
of the grammar but let's just see it in
operation first
so again i'll try to write it to you in
both ways in terms of the parse tree and
the resulting string as you're doing the
substitutions
so um
the
uh so first we start with the e
then we substitute e plus t and we see
the resulting string z plus t
but now we as we're doing additional
substitutions the resulting string that
you get is going to evolve um
accordingly
and
um so
i hope
it comes across
that this tree here picture on the left
shows you the structure of the various
substitutions whereas on the right it
just shows you the strings that you get
as a result of those substitutions
[Music]
so now you can
generate this particular string which is
now in the language of this grammar you
could generate all sorts of other
strings as well uh such as
you know parenthesis a plus a
parenthesis times a and so on
and in fact um
this might be a piece
of a programming language that you're
trying to describe
um
and one application of
context-free grammars is to describe the
syntax of programming languages you know
what are the legal programs that you can
write with in that programming language
and not only that
the
grammar can be used to automatically
generate the part of the compiler uh for
that programming language which will
interpret the um which would
uh
interpret the structure of the input you
know the so-called parser which will
figure out the meaning of the
uh input to the compiler so that the
compiler then can generate the code or
if it's an interpreter it could
interpret the uh the resulting um code
that you've given it um but the very
first step in both of those is to figure
out the meaning and the meaning is
um embedded within the structure of the
parse tree
now in the in the case of this
particular tree just to give you some
sense of what meaning i have in mind
this parse tree due to the structure of
this grammar has the precedence for
times over plus
so normally when we write down a plus a
times a you you assume you're going to
do the multiplication before you do the
addition even though it appears second
that's just the way we tend to write
things and and this grammar has grouped
it that way for you it groups the times
lower down in the tree than the plus so
the the times is going to be done
before the plus if you imagine doing
this in terms of the way the tree is
guiding you so the tree as you can see
has a certain amount of meaning built
into it now we're not actually going to
be using that in this course but i just
want to you
describe that as a an illustration of
how this material can get applied um
now so you know here is what i'm saying
that the tree contains additional
information
now that's also relevant um
if
you happen to have a grammar which might
allow multiple parse trees for the same
string
okay that can happen um
this
particular grammar does not allow that
but you might write other grammars that
as we'll see in a minute that could
generate the same string in multiple
ways with multiple different parse trees
now that might be undesirable
when you have a programming language
because
typically you want it to be only a
single meaning
for your code you don't want it to be
ambiguous and have multiple meanings
but
um
uh
ambiguity is it does occur and it's not
necessarily something we're always going
to uh see is a bad thing um so you know
i think as i mentioned last time a lot
of this subject originated with
linguistics um and that's where the
terminology comes from grammar
and um
uh
languages and so on the terminology for
the subject really comes out of
linguistics in fact one of the key
players for that is an emeritus faculty
member at mit noam chomsky he was
instrumental in setting a lot of this
stuff up um but
the
um
uh
you you can think of grammars as
applying to natural human languages as
well so
let me give you a little example as a
pop-up this is not directly uh pop-up a
check-in not directly relevant uh to the
material i just presented but just sort
of a curiosity um
if you take the english sentence the boy
saw the girl with the mirror
um
you know
does that is there only one
natural
uh interpretation for that sentence or
are there perhaps other natural
interpretations for that sentence so let
me pose that to you as another uh poll
here um and uh
so i ask you to think about how many
different meanings you might find
for
uh reasonable different meanings i mean
you can you know if
you're going to go wild you can think of
zillions of meetings but i think in
terms of reasonable meanings how many
meetings might you get for the sentence
uh
people are seeing more meetings than i'm
seeing
but that's okay
um
so this is a
quick why don't we just give this
another uh
10 seconds here
um
and then um
most of you are in agreement with me um
uh i can see here
that uh
uh
you are
uh seeing that there were two meanings
the two meanings that i see here for
this sentence are um
when you say the boys or the girl with
the mirror is who has the mirror
is it the boy seeing the girl through
the mirror
or is it the girl that has the mirror
and the boy just happens to see her so
two very different meanings for the same
sentence and that's the nature of
english it's just uh the the way um
uh it's it's an it's it's an ambiguous
um structure there and often we resolve
that ambiguity in english with other
information that we might have um but um
typically you don't want there to be
ambiguity when you have this a grammar
say describing a programming like
programming language
okay
um
so let's continue on that um
so talking a little bit more about
ambiguity i was promised you an example
where you might have an ambiguous
grammar um
so uh if you take these two grammars g2
and g3 the g2 from the last slide and g3
is a
similar grammar in fact has it's the
grammar that has the very same language
um that gives you the very same language
so l of g2 equals l of g3 both of them
are describing these arithmetical
expressions
um
but whereas g2 has a unique parse tree
for every string that you generate g3
can have multiple parse trees for the
same string
okay so i'm just going to illustrate
that here so here is the same string
that we generated last time a plus a
times a
in g3 the parse tree is actually even
simpler
here um so here i'm showing you the uh
there's just the two substitutions that
you
uh need to make starting from e and then
to to get the string a plus a times a
it's a it's a it's a simpler grammar in
a sense
um but you there's another parse tree
that'll give you the same
uh result and i've written that down
below here
upside down
um so uh the upper parse tree groups the
times before the plus
or more in more inside uh
than the plus but the lower parse tree
doesn't have that precedence built into
it and can alternatively interpret the
plus as being of higher precedence than
times and so in that sense we have here
um a grammar which is um has two
interpretations for this um
same string and we call that whoops we
call that an
an ambiguous
uh
derivation ambiguously derived string
and the grammar itself is called an
ambiguous grammar
um
uh okay
so let us continue on from that
by the way there's a question here that
came in
uh
uh like for example a plus a is that
ambiguous in g2 no
uh if you if you try to uh apply it
you'll see the way that g2 can produce a
plus a to a plus a plus a
is going to group the first two and then
the and then the the second one then the
last one you can't you can't derive
things in multiple ways um i mean
addition is associative but the grammar
doesn't
it doesn't the grammar for the grammar
um
it's going to have a prescribed order
for the way things get interpreted there
okay um so that's ambiguity um so let's
uh introduce push down automata um which
is going to be our automata counterpart
for
context-free languages
all right um so the way i'm going to
introduce push-down automata uh sort of
shifting gears here and now um
is
by first
uh giving a new view of finite automata
remember before when we presented a
finite automaton we gave it in terms of
a state diagram which i've kind of shown
here in miniature form on the picture
um
uh
we could do that for pushdown automata
but the picture tends to be very
complicated so i'm going to take a bit
of a higher level um
uh description for pushdown automata
which is i'm calling a schematic view or
a schematic diagram
and there i'm really not going to be
showing you the individual states but
i'm going to be showing you the
individual components of the machine at
a sort of more of an abstract
and from a more abstract perspective and
so from that perspective um
[Music]
a finite automaton has here what i'm
going to call the finite control so i'm
going to be suppressing the details of
the states
in this pic in this picture i'm going to
represent uh that those states as the
control
of the um of the dfa or the nfa they're
really going to be the same
from this
pictorial point of view um the input is
going to be appear on
as a string that's written down on what
we're calling a tape
again this is somewhat of an
anachronistic terminology back in my
days
people actually did feed their inputs
into computers on a tape sometimes
we don't do that so much anymore but
that terminology has stuck and it's
going to be a persisting um
uh later on in the course too so you
might as well get used to it um so the
input is going to appear on a tape or
sometimes called an input tape um and
the way the
machine actually will read that input
whoops uh is going to have a head
which is going to be
um starting at the left side and moving
from left to right reading the symbols
on the that appear on the input tape one
by one
okay so this is our picture of a an
a finite automaton
just redone
from uh last time just a different way
of picturing it now that's going to be
setting the stage for the picture of a
push down automaton because the push-on
automaton is like a finite automaton but
it has an extra feature has an extra
device attached to it and that's called
a stack
okay so here's a schematic diagram for
push down automaton
and that's going to be a stack
which is going to be
basically
a form of auxiliary
storage
now remember part of the limitation for
a finite automaton was that we had a
limited amount of memory
um
so
we were not able to do some very simple
things like counting because we had a
limited memory
so the push-on automaton is going to be
able to use its stack as a kind of
unbounded memory
but a memory that's very restricted in
the way it can be used so it's unlimited
but still restricted as we'll see
so
uh the way the push down automaton uses
um this extra memory
on on what we're calling the stack or
push down stack
is that you can write symbols
um instead of only reading symbols but
those symbols can only be read at the
very
written or read at the very top
of this list of symbols
and every time you add a new symbol the
other symbols that are already there get
pushed down hence the name people also
often refer to it as a stack of plates
uh in a cafeteria if you've ever seen
those things or you can remember back to
the days when we went to cafeteria uh
which getting further and further away
but um
uh if you have a cafeteria you had a
stack of plates and you know you as you
removed plates from them they were on a
spring and they kept coming up or if you
add more they would go down and it's the
same idea imagine these symbols here are
sort of on a um on a spring and the more
symbols you add them the more they go
down uh or if you remove them by read
and read them and remove them then they
move back up okay
so a push out of tabaton operates like a
finite like a non-deterministic finite
diameter as we'll see push down automata
for out for us are always going to be
allowed to be non-deterministic so we're
not going to be studying the
push on automata that are restricted to
be only deterministic um
uh i'll say more about that in a second
but like they operate like an nfa except
they can write
uh or
read
symbols from the top of the stack
and when they write they're adding the
symbol on pushing down that stack and
when they're reading they're removing
symbols from the stack
and thereby
lifting up the stack
okay
we give them special names so those of
you who have seen stacks already this is
you know i'm sure old hat for you
uh but
i'm sure now everyone has have seen
stacks before so uh the special name for
writing onto a stack is called a push
operation so that you're pushing a new
symbol down on the top of the stack and
it pushes everything down
whereas when you're reading a symbol and
removing it from the top of the stack
that's called a pop
so that's reading and removing
we we always think of those as going
together writing and editing and reading
and removing are combined
i mean you might wonder why can't i just
read it and leave it alone and not just
have remove it
you uh no
you can get that effect by reading it
and then uh which removes it and then
putting it back if you really want it to
stay there
but the way we're setting it up
is that
reading comes with removing writing
comes with adding
okay and they're called pushing and
popping
okay so let's do an example
um
so we have here a push down automaton
for a language we'll call d
it's a we've seen that language before
it's this uh it was um actually we use
the same uh letter for it the strings of
zeros followed by ones where the numbers
are the same of the two so zero to the k
one to the k
we couldn't do that with a finite
automaton we will be able to do that
with a push down automaton
um
and here i
uh
um i thought i wrote down the input here
but okay so the basic idea is i'm going
to give you a
uh an input
now and the pushdown of the tombiton is
supposed to test
whether that input is in the language
whether it's of this form
um
now it has
the ability to use the stack
because you know it's going to have to
count how many zeros it has and so the
way it's going to do it is you know i
have a bunch of zeros hopefully and then
a bunch of ones and you want to see that
they're uh of the same number it's going
to take the zeros and store them on the
stack
until it sees a one
and then one's going to start to read
the ones and it's going to remove the
zeros matching them off one to one with
the ones that it's seen
okay
so um you initially
first read the zeros and push them onto
the stack until you read a one and then
you read the ones uh while popping zeros
from the stack and you enter the accept
state if the stack is empty
just like with a finite automaton the
except entering the accept state only
counts when you're at the end of the
input
okay so um without me needing to say
anything it's really saying you enter
the accept state if the stack is empty
at the end of the input string but
that's kind of implicit because
it only takes effect at the end of the
input string if you enter an accept
state alone in the middle somewhere it
doesn't matter it doesn't affect
anything
um
okay uh
with that we're going to take a little
break and then we'll be back uh shortly
to look at push down automata again in a
more uh with a more formal definition
um let me put that's going to be five
minutes so if i can figure out how to
get my timer screen up here yes
and we will
uh
the camera when the candle burns down to
nothing
we will return and continue
okay
our candle has
burned down and has gone out i think i
never actually watched to see what would
happen at the end uh
so um we're good to go let's continue
um
uh
good
and let me put myself back in there
all righty
um
[Music]
so we were doing push down automata and
we just did that example of zero to the
k1 to the k
now that you have a stack
we can do uh all sorts of
fancy things that fina tamara could not
do
just with their limited
memory
okay so let's take a look at how we
define
push down automata
um
[Music]
so now uh push down automata is actually
going to be a six
tuple so it's a little bit got some
fancier stuff here to deal with not too
much but a little bit
um
and uh so it has uh let's look at these
a little bit more carefully since
there's some novelty here
we have the uh input alphabet just as we
had before
uh sigma
but we also have gamma
which is the alphabet for uh using the
stack
now um
you might ask why don't we just use the
same alphabet well it's really a matter
of convenience um
that we would like to be able to have
other symbols that uh could include the
input alphabet but could include other
things as well so it just gives you more
flexibility in terms of what you're
going to be writing on the stack
um
okay the transition function more
complicated uh so i think i don't know
if i'm going to even say what the other
things are but you know these are the
accepting states this is the starting
state so that's um the same as before
but the transition function is is a much
different animal here in a push-down
automaton so let's just try to uh unpack
that and understand what it's saying
the transition function tells us how the
machine operates how it goes from state
to state
how it's going to read the input how it
reads from the stack and what it might
write on the stack too because that's
going to all happen under program
control
so um what this means here
is that
you know when the machine is in a
particular state
um
reading a particular input symbol let's
ignore the empty string uh
subscript for the monument so it's in a
particular state
reading a particular input symbol and
with a certain
stack symbol appearing at the top of the
stack
so that's all information that's
available to the controller of this
pushdown automaton
the transition function
the current state
the next input symbol and the symbol at
the top of the stack
and once we have that
we know what new state we can go into
and what new symbol
we can write on the top of the stack
okay so that's what the uh
um right-hand side of this function
specification means so this is where uh
kind of the input to the function this
is going to be the output of the
function state entry and a new symbol to
appear on the stack so this is the
popping symbol this is the pushing
symbol
so now there are two things that bear
explanation here first of all now this
is this is a power set
so this is going to be representing as
we did before
um a non-deterministic machine
we may have several possibilities and
we're going to represent that as a set
of possibilities
for the machine that it could go to at
any point
i will give an example of how a push
down automaton uses its non-determinism
in a minute
the other thing is is these epsilons so
we have to understand why they are there
and we remember we had them for the nfas
corresponding to when the nfa had an
epsilon transition
an empty transition so it could go along
that transition without reading any
input
so this is going to play the same role
here
so if you have um instead of an input
symbol
from sigma appearing in this um uh
part of the
you know uh
for the for the transition function
instead you have an
you have an epsilon appearing
that means that the transition that that
move of the machine can happen without
reading any input symbol
just like for the nfa's
or if you have an epsilon appearing for
the stack symbol that means you can make
that transition without reading any
stack symbol
so any whatever's sitting on the top of
the stack it doesn't matter the machine
can make that move
and it won't read anything either we're
not going to pop anything it's just
going to uh be proceeding without
looking at the stack at all
or it might have both of them which case
it's going to go from one state to
another state without looking at the
input or at the top of the stack
so um
that's what the possibility of epsilon
means
for the um
for the transition function in the in
those places
the epsilon appearing over here means
something a little different but very
similar what that means is that
um
[Music]
we won't write anything on the top of
the stack that's going to be
we will go to a new state but without
doing any writing so we'll leave the
stack alone
um so here means we're not going to read
anything
if it's in this position in this
position means we're not going to write
anything
okay so all of those things are valid
and legal from the perspective of you
know constructing a push-down automaton
and i've kind of illustrated here you
know just with a little bit of an
example if you have delta that applies
to some state q
reading an input symbol a and popping a
c from the top of the stack
then you might have let's say in this
case two possibilities that you might
end up going to you might end up going
to states r1 or to states r2
and in the former case you'll end up
writing a d pushing a d onto this top of
the stack and in the latter case you
would be pushing an e onto the top of
the stack
okay so this is i'm trying to help you
look at this notation you can you know
you know i hope this is clear to you um
i'm sure for some of you it's too slow
but others of you i'm trying to help
along but if you're really struggling
with this notation at this point you
know you really have to going to have to
dig in and make sure you follow it
because it's only going to get harder
from there i'm going to stop being uh
going over these these kinds of points
and if you're still struggling you can't
get it this is not the right class for
you i'll just i'll be honest
um
because we're just gonna be
taking off like you know we're gonna
start to accelerate fairly quickly
okay so it's a non-deterministic machine
um we accept uh like we did before uh
there might be several different threads
of the computation you're going to end
up accepting um
if some of the threads
or what at least one of the threads end
up ends up in an accept state at the end
of the input string
okay
that's when we machine overall accepts
it's just the way we normally think of
non-determinism
again you can use the models that we had
before in terms of guessing or
parallelism whatever works for you and
sometimes different things work in
different different different occasions
uh but that's how non-determinism works
we'll do an example now okay here is a
push on automaton for a different
language we haven't seen before i don't
think well maybe we have um
which is
um going to be
using its non-determinism in an
essential way this is a
language that is going to where
non-determinism is going to be critical
um
without it you can't uh a deterministic
push on automaton which is something by
the way that people study um and there's
a section of my book about that section
2.4 because it has relevance to
applications we're not going to address
that in this course so you can just skip
section 2.4 it's pretty technical uh
i'll have to say um but still
quite interesting and beautiful if
you're if you like that stuff but it's
technical we won't do it
um
so here is um this input string
w w reverse
for all possible w's over our alphabet
zero one and what w reverse by the way
means is writing w backwards
uh so this is all strings followed by
a reversal of the same string
okay the string written backwards um
really you can think of these as uh um
you know so these are strings that um
well here's an example like 0 1 1
1 1 0 the string written backwards so
this is a string in the language
appearing on a tape as i as i described
okay so how is the machine going to um
recognize this language it's kind of
pretty similar somewhat similar to
before but with one important difference
um and if you imagine i think again i
like to use this kind of and
anthropomorphizing these things putting
yourself in the place of the machine
and thinking how you would do it
um
so if you imagine getting these symbols
one by one zero one one you don't know
what's coming next as you're getting the
symbols
you have to figure out how to match off
the second half with the first half so
you're gonna put the first half on the
stack
and then
you're gonna remove the first half and
match it off with the with the
with the second half
con conveniently the first half comes
out backwards the stack is a first in
last out kind of thing so um
it comes out in reverse order so that's
perfect for matching off with the second
half
uh but the tricky part
with this language
is how do you know when you're at the
when you're at the middle because you
don't get to see
um the rest
you only get to see what you've seen so
far you don't know what's coming
so you know
uh
when you read that second one at this
point you read zero one one now you're
reading that second one you don't know
that perhaps there's just going to be a
zero following that and it's going to be
all
so maybe you should be deciding to that
this point here that i've marked um uh
is the
midpoint and you you
put zero one on the tape and then start
popping the second the
the second one and matching it off with
the first one um that might that would
be a tempting thing to do but you just
don't know
um and that's where the non-determinism
is going to be essential so let me let
me write down more of this so what
you're going to do is you're going to
read and push input symbols but not
deterministically guessing that you're
at the middle so you're going to now
deterministically either repeat that and
continue to read and push symbols onto
the stack or you're going to go to two
deciding that
or guessing that you're at the midpoint
and now it's time to start reading and
popping instead of reading and pushing
so you're going to read input symbols
and popping that popping the stack
symbols comparing the
the two the the symbols that you're
reading with the top the symbols you're
removing from the stack
if they ever disagree
then this thread of the non-determinism
rejects
because
either the input is not in the language
or at least you've made a wrong choice
as to where the midpoint is
um
and then you're going to enter the
accept state if the stack is empty
and ignore this part for the moment of
this software reference uh
let's just um i'll speak to that in a
second but um i just want to make sure
we understand that at an intuitive level
how this machine is using its
non-determinism
to
uh recognize this language because the
non-determinism is critical and it's
important that you understand it um
so let me just make some side comments
and then we'll come back to this
software remark so first of all
one question that comes up a lot
well um not paying attention to the chat
here sorry so if you're not getting
answer from me try the tas but um one of
the
uh
one of the um questions that comes up a
lot when they're thinking about
non-determinism for push down automata
is what happens to the stack
the stack gets replicated
in the non-determinism every time the
machine forks just like everything else
gets replicated so an entire every time
there's a fork in the non-determinism
and the machine branches into multiple
possibilities the entire machine
replicates the current state the current
position of the head the what's the
stack and its contents all of that gets
replicated um and the two
um
sides of the the two branches or the two
sides of the fork each go on
independently in their merry way
okay doing their own thing independently
and then if any one of them accepts
that's the only way there's sort of a
kind of a communication because the one
that accepts raises the flag and then uh
the overall machine is set to accept
okay so the non-deterministic forks
replicate the stack of saying it uh just
want to make sure you've got that
um and then this language requires
non-determinism that that i said earlier
um so our pda push down time model is
going to be non-deterministic i mean you
might have examples which are
deterministic but the model is going to
always allow non-determinism okay what's
this bit about the software
so if you look at this formal definition
here it doesn't have anywhere in it the
ability to test if the stack is empty
that's not part of the hardware
specification at least as we are
describing it for a push-down automaton
you can might imagine someone somebody
else describes push on the tama in some
other way which gives that as a
primitive but we're not going to do that
why because we don't need a primitive
for that you can get the effect
of testing if there's an empty stack
even if you don't have that as a
primitive for the machine
because
uh what you could do is you can start
the machine off when it very at the very
first thing it does is it writes a
special symbol to mark um the bottom you
know what's going to eventually be the
bottom of the stack there's going to be
some special symbol maybe a dollar sign
symbol
that's the very first thing that the
machine does and then it proceeds as
before if ever sees that dollar sign
symbol again it knows the stack is
effectively empty
okay so you can get the effect of
testing for the stack being empty even
if you don't have a primitive for that
and we're not going to actually fuss
about some details like that um so you
can use when you're writing your
homework sets you can just use the
assumption that you can test for empty
stack which is what i'm going to do
myself
okay
um
so uh let's continue on um
all right so
yeah so now what we're going to do we're
going to prove our one
so far we really haven't proved anything
we've just given some definitions and
some examples today was going to now
we're going to come to our big theorem
which actually is um important and has
some meat to it um and that is
how do we convert you know i claim that
to put context-free grammars and push
down automata are equivalent
well we're going to prove that
equivalence in one direction converting
the grammars to push down automata
okay so
um let me show you how that goes in some
ways
um
it's a nice proof not super complicated
but it has some meat to it
uh
so if i give you a grammar here
what i'm going to tell you how to do is
convert that grammar into push down
automaton which does the same language
okay so
if you're
checked out for a minute please come
back because we're sort of starting this
topic now that you can think a bit about
this
good good uh re-entry point if you're
sort of uh been doing something else
which i can't tell good thing uh
so all right so converting a given
grammar to a push down automaton how is
that going to work
so the idea is
okay
actually before i tell you the idea
let's just think about it together
again i like to think about the push
down automaton building a push on
automaton the way you would do it
so
a grammar is a generation device it
generates strings a push down automaton
or thinking about it as you you're a
recognizer you're given an input and you
want to know is it in the language so
you want to know is it possible for that
grammar to generate that input you're
given
so how are you going how are you going
to how are you going to do that um and
uh
are you going how are you going to um
test if the
input is in the language of the grammar
well the thing that you would naturally
do is you say well can i derive that
string using the rules of the grammar
let me start with the start string
and try to do substitutions
and see if i get the string
i'm given
and if i can get it then i know it's in
the language
right that's a natural thing to do
you're just going to try try to do so
you know try to do the substitutions
even get to the string now the thing is
there are many there might be many
different substitutions that you could
make
and you know that seems like a really
challenging uh hard thing to figure out
which substitutions to use among the
many possibilities that's where
non-determinism is going to come in
because you can think of yourself as
guessing which substitutions to make and
you're always going to make the right
guess
so the choices of which substitutions to
make that's not going to be a
problem for you that's going to be
managed by the non-determinist so
imagine you're always going to make the
right substitution but now the challenge
is how do you keep track
of the intermediate results as you're
doing those substitutions
um
and
that's where the stack is going to come
in the machine is going to write down
those intermediate results on the stack
but even there there's a subtlety that's
an important subtlety that you have to
look at so let's try
pulling that together so far before i
get to that subtlety
uh okay so as i mentioned
um
uh
the push down automaton is is going to
start out with the starting variable and
is going to guess to be guessing the
substitutions to make it's going to keep
the intermediate results on the stack
when it's done doing all the
substitutions and it has only terminal
strings on the stack it can compare with
the input and see if it got the right
thing
so if it made it all the right guesses
so you think of it as guessing doing the
right guesses but in the end you have to
check to make sure that you've got the
right the you that you did all the right
thing and you accept when when things um
have matched up you know you and you
made all the right guesses so you have
to in the end you have to check that you
actually got
that input uh
from doing those substitutions
okay so let's let's let's try to see
this
operating in action and then you'll see
the subtlety the the delicacy the the
the the
the a problem that's going to arise
hopefully you're following at least in
part what i'm just saying so far
okay so here is the input
we do know that that's an input in the
language of the we we've been seeing
this example multiple times so here's
the input appearing on the input tape a
plus a times a
now the push on automaton is supposed to
be accepting that input because it's in
the language of the ground
okay so it's going to operate by first
writing
to start off the starting variable on
the stack
and then doing the substitutions as
we're going along
okay so um
we're going to substitute we we we uh e
goes to e plus t
so we do that first substitution
um and then
we do the next substitution here the e
so i'm i'm if you're looking at this
tree here that means this is the right
tree for that uh
for that input so we we substitute e by
t
uh so far so good the automaton can do
to make that substitution
then the next substitution is going to
be a little uh so we're where e plus t
we did we substitute here we got t plus
t and now we're going to substitute the
t times f which is this t over here we
want to substitute that and that appears
as t times f now on the stack
now if you're following me you should be
suddenly getting nervous
because
we just cheated
it's okay
um doing substitution doing these
replacements at the very top of the
stack because the push down automaton
has access to the top that's how stacks
work
but it does not have access deep down
within the stack
that is
uh not house style that is not how
stacks work so that's cheating
but
ignoring the cheating for the minute if
you could replace those um
do those substitutions deep down within
the stack this would all work we would
be good you would do the substitutions
uh one after another until you ended up
with no uh variables and then you have
the string here and you're going to
match it off and compare it with the
input it's all done in the right way so
that the things are in the right order
so the
you know the
after all the substitutions you'd have a
plus a times a sitting here on the stack
you match you compare that with the
input it's going to match up and you'll
end up accepting
all good so how do we deal with that
problem here problem access below the
stack of step top of stack is cheating
what are we going to do instead
so the idea is actually pretty simple
well if you've understood what i've said
so far the you know fixing that is
actually not too bad um
uh
sort of fading out here
put some more light on the
on my image
um
so
how do we do that uh
how do we get the effect of the access
below the top of the stack
and the way we're going to do that is um
by making the obs what we're going to do
we're only going to do substitutions
that we can make at the top of the stack
so whenever there's a variable at the
top of the stack we're going to do the
substitution because we the top we can
access
now what happens if we have a terminal
symbol sitting at the top blocking our
way from accessing variable variables
below
well
actually that's an easy case to handle
because we have terminal symbols sitting
on the top they're never going to change
anyway so you might as well match them
with the input at that time
so when you have a terminal
sitting at the top we'll just read
another input symbol and do it and match
it off there
and we just keep reading the terminal
symbols off until we have a variable
sitting on the top then we do a
substitution
um and we keep substituting variables
until we have a terminal then we read it
then we compare it with the input
and in so doing um we will end up
getting the same effect that i described
before without ever needing to dig down
into the into the interior of the stack
and doing substitutions there they're
all going to rise up to the top uh and
we can always do them at the top
okay um so anyway uh you know i forgot
to do that here so instead
only substitute variables when they're
at the top of the stack uh if a terminal
is on the top pop it and compare with
the input and reject if they're not
equal so if you ever have something
which is not matching the way it's
supposed to do that i mean that thread
is just gonna
fail you know then it was not
a bad
uh non-deterministic choice was made or
maybe the input was not in the language
anyway and there are no no good choices
um
so here my animation broke here so let
me just
put the whole thing up in front of you
so here is the actual construction
um
push the start symbol on the stack
if the top of the stack uh is a variable
replace it with a corresponding
right-hand side
doing a non-deterministic choice among
the various possibilities
if it's a terminal you pop it and match
it with the next input symbol and if the
stack is empty you accept
so here is how the stack would actually
look for this particular input
you know it would start off the same
you'd have e and then substitute with e
plus t
and then
we're going to always substitute do the
substitutions at the top
so e gets substituted by f
oh is that right
no
this slide i
messed up i apologize so e gets
substituted by t which gets substituted
by f
um and the point is that when you get to
an a sitting at the top uh forgive the
typos here
now we have a terminal symbol and that's
going to get matched off with the next
input symbol
and get removed and now we have just the
plus and the t left
and then the plus is also a terminal
symbol that's going to get matched over
the next thing we just have a t sitting
on the top and now we can do a
substitution
okay so that's how uh it works
okay i that's all i wanted to say i
think um oh yeah there's one just
remarked so this is not we're not going
to prove this but i think it's uh i i do
need to say this that actually you can
do the conversion in the other direction
too you can convert a um
so
a is a context-free language if and only
if
some push-down automaton recognizes a
and
um if you haven't
seen if and only if it's a it's an
expression i'm going to use
uh
uh again over and over so you should get
used to it it stands for if and only if
and which just means the implication
goes both ways so a is an uh
context-free
context-free language implies that some
push on time time recognizes a and vice
versa
um so there's really two things you need
to prove whenever you have an if and
only if you have to prove both
directions um
so uh thinking about that way splitting
them in half um the the forward
direction we've already proved
converting a push
context
uh free grammar to a push down on
automaton the reverse direction we're
not going to prove it's in the book if
you're curious
and you're responsible knowing that the
fact is true but you don't have to know
the proof
uh which is a somewhat comp a little bit
complicated and
you know i think it would take us too
long to go through it so you're not
responsible for it
um
so there's a last check in here that i
have for you
which is just a question uh
uh which you can answer based on the
material that we presented so far is
every regular language also a
context-free language
just yes no or
you're not sure
so let me launch that as a poll here
okay about to close
um
[Music]
ending polling
and sharing results
this one i think you you pretty much uh
most of you got some of you uh
are not sure
um
every language is in fact a context-free
language
um
and the way to see that is that every
regular language can be done by a dfa or
an nfa as we already showed
and um
dfa or an nfa is really just a push-on
automaton that never uses its stack
so
you can always think of a dfa as a push
down automaton and we already argued
that pushdown automata
are equivalent to context-free grammars
and so they do the context-free
languages
so anything that you can do with a dfa
you can also do with a push-down
automaton and so is therefore uh um
all the regular languages are also
context-free languages
okay so with that let's just uh kind of
pull things together
um a little quick recap as to what we've
been doing so far in the class we have
the regular languages and the
context-free languages
we had the two forms of sort of getting
at them the recognizer form which is
like the automata based perspective
like either a dfa or an nfa in the case
of the regular languages push down
automaton for the context-free languages
and for the generators we had the
regular expression
uh for the regular languages and the
context-free grammars for the for the
contextual languages okay
um and as we just pointed out in our
most in our last check-in the regular
languages form a subset and in fact a
proper subset of the context-free
languages uh as shown in this venn
diagram because we have already
exhibited languages that are
context-free but not regular
all right
so quick review we've defined the
context-free grammars and their
associated languages the context-free
languages we define push-down automata
and we showed how to convert context
free grammars to push down automatic
um
and that's all i have for you today
okay here's a question i'll answer to
everybody why do we strict ourselves to
a stack why don't we use random access
memory we will use random access memory
um for the next model called the turing
machine and we're going to introduce
that i think next to the next lecture so
that's going to be the
model that we're going to stick with
throughout the term
but we have not uh we were kind of using
introducing weaker models
uh as a kind of a prelude uh to the more
general purpose uh computational model
um
uh
really to get ourselves
warmed up
and also um because
um
for the weaker models you can fully
analyze them
um in a way that you cannot return
machines you you will be able to as you
will see
you can
determine properties of languages for
the weaker models that you cannot for
the more general models and so
i think that's helpful to have that
perspective that
you know for some cases you can get get
a full analysis and some other cases you
cannot um
but anyway um
that's the reason why we're stricter
restricted to the stack besides the fact
that these models have applications um
that i think are
worth
you people seeing
um
why yeah some reason we chose a stack
well why did we choose a stack and not
some other data structure for our uh
temporary for our our extra storage
and the reason
for a stack for one thing the stack is
what is exactly what you need to get to
the correspondence with context-free
grammars
um if you use some other
storage like the queue for example
instead of a stack in fact you get a
very different outcome and
it's an actually interesting exercise to
see what happens what do you get if you
use a queue as an external storage
instead of as a stack uh
it's a good homework problem maybe i'll
assign it
um
uh let's see um
nfa
okay
uh
we showed so
um
we
we showed that non-determinism can be
eliminated for finite automata so nfas
and dfas are equivalent
uh what about for for pushdown automata
uh the answer is no they're not
equivalent i think i mentioned that
earlier but i don't mind repeating it
there are certain languages that can be
done only with non-deterministic push
down automata and cannot be done with
deterministic push down automata for
example that language w w reverse
that requires the non-determinism in
order for the machine to be able to
guess where the middle is
so um okay i'm gonna head off uh thank
you guys see you on tuesday
you